Як люди можуть так чинити одне з одним? У голові не вкладається!
Ці молоді німці - християни, євреї та мусульмани - відвідали колишній концентраційний табір "Аушвіц",
який став свідченням чи не найжахливіших злочинів проти єврейського народу. Тут було вбито мільйони євреїв.
Сьогодні "Аушвіц" - це меморіальний музей, який повертає жертвам Голокосту людське обличчя.
Страшно бачити, скільки страждань можуть заподіяти іншим люди, маючи владу.
Це просто шок. Мені потрібен час, щоб прийти до тями.
Сьогодні ми сприймаємо "Аушвіц" як музей, але за цим - мільйони людських життів.
Цього літа я вперше побувала у колишньому концентраційному таборі, у "Бухенвальді".
І думала, що тепер готова відвідати "Аушвіц". Але він виявився ще жахливішим.
Ці молоді люди приїхали сюди з власної волі - екскурсію для них влаштувала німецька некомерційна організація,
яка має на меті зблизити представників різних релігій. Людей, які інакше навряд чи зустрілися б.
Якщо чесно, до цієї екскурсії я заледве коли-небудь перетиналася з євреями. Мені не доводилося спілкуватися з ними.
"Аушвіц-1" був першим із цілого комплексу концтаборів. Лише у ньому загинули від шістдесяти до сімдесяти тисяч людей.
Щойно ми увійшли на територію табору, я подумала: "Так ось де все це відбувалося".
Коли ж ми вже зайшли в будівлі і побачили всі ці зображення та фотографії, мене захлеснула хвиля емоцій.
У якийсь момент я взагалі перестала щось сприймати.
У голові ти вже маєш якесь уявлення про те, що там відбувалося.
Але це не йде в жодне порівняння з реальністю: все було в тисячу разів гірше.
Я приїхала, знаючи, які жахи там коїлися. Але тепер мені про це відомо значно більше.
Я дізналася, де саме це відбувалося. Все дуже докладно пояснюється.
Це так сильно на мене подіяло, що я, здається, просто вимкнулася. Я ніби убезпечила себе від емоцій, абстрагувалася - і від цього мені стало ніяково.
Тому що мені здалося, що це якось не по-людськи - нічого не відчувати, не плакати і не переживати, хоча там сталися такі жахіття.
"Аушвіц-2", він же "Біркенау", був найбільшим німецьким табором смерті. Його збудували, коли першого вже не вистачало.
Тут нацисти знищили близько одного мільйона ста тисяч людей.
Більшість убито в газових камерах, де для цього застосовувався отруйний газ "Циклон Бе".
Щодня тисячі жертв спускалися цими сходами у величезну роздягальню, і тільки тоді розуміли,
що душові кімнати насправді були замаскованими газовими камерами.
Близько дев'ятисот тисяч людей було отруєно газом відразу після прибуття до табору.
Я думала, що плакатиму без перестанку, бо я доволі емоційна людина.
Але в мене взагалі плакати не виходило - настільки гнітючою була атмосфера.
Мене лише охопила лють на людей, які виявилися здатними на таке.
Мені здається, так буває, коли одразу стільки людей щось роблять – у тому числі щось жахливе – інші думають: ну, не можуть вони всі помилятися.
Жертвами стали мільйони людей, кожен з яких мав свою історію. Нацисти відібрали у в'язнів усе, що в них було - навіть їхнє волосся.
Я туди зазирнула. Спочатку нас повели до іншої зали, ліворуч. А праворуч було приміщення зі скляними вітринами, і в них - волосся.
Я побіжно на все це поглянула і подумала: "Ні, я не хочу йти туди".
Особливо всі ці особисті речі: дитячі черевики, протези, милиці. Від їхнього вигляду і справді ставало страшно.
Одна річ дивитися на фотографії в інтернеті, а зовсім інше побачити все це на власні очі.
Нацисти задокументували імена всіх шести мільйонів євреїв, яких вони знищили.
Списки можна знайти у Державному музеї "Аушвіц-Біркенау".
Я спочатку подумала, що на одній сторінці буде максимум одне чи два імені, не більше, але ні
– там взагалі не залишалося вільного місця, все було заповнено іменами.
Тоді я почала шукати наше прізвище і виявила ось такий стос сторінок з тими, хто має таке саме.
Моє прізвище - Баум. Тут загалом, здається, сторінок п'ять Баумів.
Люди, мені здається, не розуміють, що за кожним іменем у цих списках стоїть людина, яка незадовго до своєї загибелі
насолоджувалась життям у колі рідних та близьких. І якій навіть на думку не спадало, що таке може статися.
Деякі євреї не тікали і не ховалися, бо просто не вірили, що таке в принципі можливо.
Група також відвідала популярне серед туристів місто Краків на півдні Польщі.
Тут молоді німці різних релігій змогли познайомитися ближче, що також було метою цієї поїздки.
Похід у місцеву синагогу дав їм зрозуміти, що у цьому розділі історії Німеччини неможливо раз і назавжди поставити крапку.
Країна повинна й надалі нести за це відповідальність.
Німеччина має визнавати свою провину. І ніколи про неї не забувати.
Учасники також обговорювали міжнародні конфлікти, зокрема, конфлікт на Близькому Сході та ізраїльсько-палестинські відносини.
Коли бачиш, що чиниться несправедливість – абсолютно неважливо, хто це робить.
Навіть якщо ці люди або, скажімо, держава, самі є жертвами, і при цьому раптом з'ясовується, що вони, своєю чергою,
пригнічують інших або змушують їх страждати - у будь-якому разі необхідно добитися того, щоб справедливість перемогла.
Все має бути так само, як і щодо будь-якої іншої країни. А ще Європа зобов'язана стежити за тим,
щоб міжнародного права дотримувалися інші держави, і критикувати ті країни, які його порушують.
При цьому ніхто, звісно, ​​не повинен палити ізраїльські прапори. Адже Ізраїль такий довгоочікуваний притулок для єврейського народу.
На зустрічі перед ними виступила одна із наймолодших жертв Голокосту.
Стефанія Верник народилася в листопаді 1944 року в таборі смерті "Аушвіц-Біркенау".
Я - дитина, яка народилася в пеклі.
Стефанія Верник розповіла гостям із Німеччини, що її мати прибула до табору вже вагітною.
Але приховала цей факт під час відбору в'язнів, побоюючись, щоб її відразу не відправили на смерть.
Мою маму разом із іншими жінками доставили до табору на вантажівці.
На в'їзді їх зустріла німкеня-наглядачка з привілейованих, або капо, як їх називали.
Вона їм сказала: "Ви прибули до табору смерті. Звідси лише одна дорога: через димар".
Незабаром на світ з'явилася Стефанія Верник. Новонароджена дівчинка привернула увагу доктора Йозефа Менгеле,
сумнозвісного лікаря, який проводив експерименти над ув'язненими.
Доктор Менгеле регулярно приходив зі своїм помічником і забирав мене для проведення оглядів.
Мама розповідала мені, що після цього мене неможливо було заспокоїти.
Я не знаю, що вони там зі мною робили, що мені давали, які псевдонаукові дослідження вони проводили.
Ніхто не знає, що саме там відбувалося.
Коли у січні тисяча дев'ятсот сорок п'ятого радянські війська звільнили "Аушвіц", мати з дочкою нарешті опинилися в безпеці.
Стефанії Верник вдалося вижити і тепер, у свої майже сімдесят сім, вона оточена турботою своєї сім'ї.
Сім'я у мене велика: нас тридцять три особи!
На згадку про душі шести мільйонів євреїв, що стали жертвами Голокосту на території Європи,
які були вбиті, умертвлені, спалені і загинули, віддаючи Господу славу імені Його.
Мені здається, що багато хто зараз - особливо люди мого покоління - більше готові прийняти людей інших національностей,
інших релігійних переконань, і взагалі в цілому більш толерантні, ніж представники попередніх поколінь.
Мені б так хотілося, щоб історія нас чогось навчила, але сумніваюся, що це можливо.
Я не вірю, що подібне може статися сьогодні.